You did thrown the guy who many people,
including me were saying as of is a very good argument for the best welterweight
ever.
I felt like Tyron is like,
you gotta give it,
there's like two does,
legendary status,
right?
There's like Matt Hughes has legendary status for being the original.
He was one of the first wrestlers who really knew who to submit guys and then
George St Pierre was of course many people's eyes.
The greatest of all time in the welterweight division went on this long run,
but I was like,
man,
when you,
if Tyron beats ooze,
mono is like,
there's a real good argument for him being number one of all time beaten.
Wonderboy beat smashed and Darrin tail beaten.
Damien Maia knocking out Robbie Lawler to win the title.
Absolutely.
I considered him.
I put him in that conversation.
Now he's in that conversation for sure.
For sure.
I put them in that conversation.
I ain't know nothing but respect for tiring.
It was nice to see afterwards.
It was,
there's a video of you and Tyrons mom and tiring and Tara's mom after it is a
beautiful video.
Yeah,
man.
It's a tear jerker I freaking,
I let it go cause I'm one of those guys,
I never really sit and stop and smell the roses and things like that.
I always,
I always have a chip on my shoulder and I'll explain why that is.
But I always had this chip on my shoulder with everything that I do.
So I never really sit and celebrate and say,
Oh yeah,
I accomplished this or I did that or did that.
But I had known,
I known his mom.
I've met her previously to to that,
the fights.
I fought in Saint Louis one time,
man,
of course I'd seen her several times at his fights,
but I'll have fighting in Saint Louis and I was there early and she was at the
hotel tire,
wasn't fighting or anything,
but she just came to the hotel.
I think she was just hanging out and I got to sit with her before,
like all the fighters even came into town.
I had to sit with her.
I think we sat for a couple of hours,
maybe three,
four hours just talking.
I got to know her and she was,
she was just such an angel,
but at the same time,
she's,
she's a gangster to like you can,
you can,
you know,
she sees everything.
And the only thing,
the biggest thing I could compare it to is if you ever seen that show for way
backs called touched by an angel,
and I forget what her name is.
She's like the famous like black actress.
And um,
do you remember that woman's name?
I forget her name.
What does that my Angelo,
it was,
it wasn't,
no,
it wasn't my Angela,
it was that late.
I mean,
she was my Angela status,
how big as she was and inspirational.
But that's Kinda what I compare her too.
And so we got,
we got,
you know,
I knew her and Tyron obviously wasn't who I would have chosen to take the belt
from,
but is how long can you hold yourself back?
Because being a chain,
there's a huge entire sent himself.
There's a huge difference between being a challenge and a champion.
And of course I,
I need,
I needed to have my family in that,
that argument.
I,
I need,
I need to get them to that status to where now setting my daughter up and I'm
setting everyone up for,
you know,
life better,
life forever.
And I couldn't continue to hold that back.
So yeah,
it was unfortunate that I had to take that from him and I kind of,
in a sense,
I felt like I was taken away from what he was doing for them.
So when I saw her walking backstage,
I just couldn't control it.
I just let,
I just let go and I just couldn't help but cry on her shoulders
does a great,
it's a great video.
What is,
her name was women's actresses.
Roma.
Downey ramen.
Yeah.
Yeah,
that's right there.
The video is amazing cause she's hugging you and she's telling you
congratulations and she's telling you that they're coming,
they're going to be coming for you.
So train hard.
Yeah.
And just like her attitude,
man.
It's,
it's beautiful man.
it's amazing her character that she handled that,
I mean this is her baby.
Her baby just lost and lost every round and it was a pretty dominant victory by
you and for her to treat you that way afterwards just shows amazing character.
Yeah,
it's,
there.
It is right here.
You can see it up here.
Look at her.
She's embraces you.
Open arms.
It's all good.
It's all good baby.
Look at that.
Oh
amazing.
That's an amazing woman right there.
All work for a couple of phone calls.
So you take it too.
It's all good.
Wow.
That's amazing man.
Yeah.
And even tiring the way tire and hit.
It's crazy,
right?
It makes me cry.
So I'm in the air over here.
I got to do it.
I got it made me cry when I saw it.
It's making me cry now.
Yeah,
man.
And the way she treated tire and to the same thing.
I mean,
she's just,
that's,
and that's,
that's kind of,
that's how my mom is to that.
So I felt such a connection to that to her because my mom is the exact same way.
My mom would've done the same thing to tire it.
And um,
it just,
it was powerful,
man.
It was moving.
And because it's,
and it goes to a test to how,
how the sport has,
how bay the sport is as well.
Yeah.
Like it's not all man,
it's just a regular fight.
You guys hate each other and you're fighting.
No,
this was a competition.
Yeah.
You know,
this was two men that went in there too for a competition and one guy,
one.
And you know,
you saw the aftermath.
They see the family receive each other.
Yeah.
I love that man.
They love when people put all that bullshit aside.
I mean,
you guys had a lot of trash talk at the press conferences and there was a lot of
that going on,
but that sells tickets and it's good for everybody and it's natural and normal.
But after it was over the,
it was nothing but respect.